Narrator: WE'RE IN A SUPERMARKET
IN HAARLEM, NETHERLANDS...
THIS WAS A CRACKING IDEA.
Narrator: ...WHERE HOME
EGG-SPERIMENTER OLWEN WILLS
IS HATCHING A PLAN.
Ruben: THE ASTONISHING THING
ABOUT THIS CLIP
IS NOT THAT A QUAIL
HATCHED OUT OF AN EGG.
IT'S THAT A QUAIL HATCHED OUT
OF A SUPERMARKET EGG.
THAT DOES NOT USUALLY HAPPEN.
Narrator: MEET ALBERT,
THE HOME-GROWN QUAIL CHICK.
I WANT ONE.
Narrator: BUT IF SUPERMARKET
EGGS DON'T NORMALLY HATCH,
HOW DID ALBERT BEAT THE ODDS?
WHEN OLWEN GOT THE EGGS HOME,
HE PUT THEM IN AN INCUBATOR
AT 37 DEGREES CELSIUS,
OR 99 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
THE TEMPERATURE IS IMPORTANT.
TOO HIGH OR TOO LOW
AND THE EMBRYO INSIDE THE EGG
WILL DEVELOP ABNORMALLY.
IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO TURN
THE EGGS OVER REGULARLY
TO KEEP THE EMBRYO
FROM STICKING TO THE SHELL.
SO OLWEN DID THIS
WITH HIS 12 EGGS
AND 19 DAYS LATER,
ONE OF THEM HATCHED
AND OUT CAME
A JAPANESE QUAIL NAMED ALBERT.
Narrator: BUT WHY DID
ONLY ONE EGG HATCH?
FOR AN EGG TO HATCH, A ROOSTER
HAS TO MATE WITH A HEN
PRIOR TO THE EGG BEING LAID
SO THE EGG CAN BE FERTILIZED.
NOW IN MOST COMMERCIAL
EGG-LAYING OPERATIONS,
THEY KEEP THE HENS AND ROOSTERS
COMPLETELY SEPARATE
TO AVOID FERTILIZATION.
THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF POSSIBLE EXPLANATIONS
FOR WHY ALBERT WAS ABLE
TO DEFY THE ODDS.
FIRST, A ROGUE MALE COULD HAVE
EITHER BEEN MISIDENTIFIED
OR PERHAPS SNUCK INTO
WHERE SOME FEMALES WERE.
ADDITIONALLY SOME FREE-RANGE
FARMS MAY KEEP ONE OR TWO MALES.
AND IT'S FOUND THAT THIS CHANGES
SOCIAL STRUCTURE,
REDUCES AGGRESSION,
AND ACTUALLY KEEPS
THE FEMALES FEELING SAFE.
SO INEVITABLY, SOME OF THEM
WILL BE CARRYING
FERTILIZED EGGS.
YOUR SUPERMARKET EGGS ARE NOT
GONNA HATCH ON THEIR OWN.
AND THEY ARE
PERFECTLY SAFE TO EAT.
Narrator:
AND HERE'S ALBERT NOW,
ALL GROWN UP AND HAVING
A QUAIL OF A TIME.